hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy
i am excited today to be talking to
phoenicia hubbard who is with nwea one
of our partner organizations that we'll
talk more about in a minute she is the
professional learning design coordinator
so i'm excited to talk to her about
professional learning for teachers
before we get started i want to remind
everyone that khan academy is a
non-profit organization and we are able
to do our work through donations from
people like you if you go to khan
academy.org
donate you will find a
way that you can help us continue this
work through your donations thank you
i also want to recognize some of our
sponsors who really helped support us
through the covet 19 crisis
and that includes bank of america at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors thank you
and finally if you
have missed some other ed talks in
homerooms you can find us uh audio
versions of those talks on your favorite
podcast provider at
looking for homeroom with sal and you
can listen to sal and i interview other
folks who are our influencers in the
education world
and with that let me welcome fanisha
finisha welcome thanks for joining us
hi kristen thank you so much for having
me
absolutely so first let me just give a
quick background for folks on uh who is
nwea
so nwea as i said is is one of our
partner organizations and they're a
non-profit that supports students and
educators
in more than 146 countries doing
research assessment solutions
policy and advocacy services
professional learning and school
improvement services and i know that
that core to nwa's work is really
fighting for equity driving impacting
classrooms and pushing for
systemic change in our education
communities so that is a big bunch of
work to to bite off tell me what your
role is
kristin i love being at nwea i've been
at nwa for about 10 years and what i do
is really support our educators
nationwide and i do that by designing
the professional learning that teachers
need to stay on top of their craft
i really enjoy the work
that is awesome how did you get into
that how did you get to be in this in
this role supporting teachers
i think to support teachers in this way
you had to have been a teacher so that's
how i started my career i started
teaching middle school math
in a very large school district and it
was in through an alternative
certification program for career
changers so these were people who had
established careers they said you know
what i really want to support students
and so started off doing that and then
was very quickly um immersed into the
world of professional learning and so i
started designing learning for teachers
coaching teachers in math and that led
me to where i am today that is awesome
so i mentioned that one of the things
that nwa does is research and
understanding more about student
learning and i know you've just released
a report on learning during covid what
were the kinds of questions you were
investigating
yeah great question our research team
kristen really wanted to see how
students were faring during the pandemic
that was our main focus and what we
noticed is that if we focus on the good
gains were made right these were very
challenging two years but gains were
made however
students showed a lower performance
compared to the past trends
and when we think about math education
there were declines in math across all
the grades and all the groups so we
think about
um but you have a nice visual there
the largest declines in math kristen
were among students of color
and students in high poverty schools and
so i think one of the biggest things we
should do right now is probably talk
about what are we going to do about it
absolutely i i like the positive that
people did learn something over the
over the the pandemic but
didn't get as far as as we would have
liked them to get likely so let's start
with parents and thinking about parents
first what can parents do to support
students in learning math
that is the question particularly
because so many of our young people
spent good quality time with their
parents these past couple years so i
know that question was coming up
repeatedly as a parent how can i support
my child what do i need to do
i think kristin what we really want to
encourage parents to do is get their
students talking about math we want to
help young people get their thoughts out
of their heads and let it come out and
come through in the best way that
students can do that
um i think
we can actually learn a lot from our
young people
in the sense that students always ask
why why why does this work why why do i
do it that way i think as parents we
need to do that same thing get our start
asking why a lot more of our students um
particularly when they come to us and
they might say hey can you help me work
through this problem or i don't
understand um throw that question out
there well
why would you do this and why does this
work and why do you think that and i
think that helps us to really get
insight into how students are thinking
about math and the ways that they think
about it
that makes sense i've i've heard
friends who are parents
worry about what do they do if they
don't know the answer if they don't know
how to
do a math problem that their their child
brings to them any suggestions for that
i think khan academy has a great
suggestion but
i wasn't leading trying to lead you
there
before we start seeking external
resources like khan academy is a great
external resource but i think
really having the students
step into the position of an empowered
learner with their parent is going to be
key so empowered learner meaning
you know what i do bring something to
the table i do have something that i
understand about the content but i also
have a stumbling block and so if i can
come to the table and start talking
through
my misconceptions as a parent what you
can do is just help guide my thinking
help pull it out of me you don't need to
know all the content to do that you just
need to know how to ask really good
questions and how to read me as your
child and understand my body language
and the things that i might be stumbling
on and the things i'm confident about
that makes sense and i know there's good
research to support that using the
language of math and just talking about
math as as being really important and
learning outcomes so that totally makes
sense to it's about having the
conversation sometimes instead of having
to find the right answer right away but
that brings true right
all right so
what about teachers we've got this idea
of these these maybe learning gaps that
have have opened up where where students
aren't where
they might have been in the past coming
into the new year what should teachers
be thinking about to address some of
that
that's a really good question too i
think
one we should all come to an agreement
that there was a lot of interrupted
learning that took place and i think
once people are okay with admitting that
you know what there were some breaks in
the routines and how we learned and
because of that interrupted learning
students might have some unfinished
learning and the unfinished learning are
like the skills and the prerequisite
knowledge that students might need in
order to be ready to learn what's coming
next and so i think teachers are well
positioned right now
to really assess
what
unfinished learning students might have
and they can do that through the use of
assessments um the data can tell us what
students might be ready to learn what
they might
have already mastered and we can do that
through actual tests and we can also do
that through formative assessment which
is something that teachers do so
skillfully every day and that's
informal ways to get data to inform
instruction right on the spot real time
what are some of your favorite of those
kind of more informal things that
teachers do to start to understand where
students are and what their skills are
oh that's a great question i love math
language routines and so i think about
a math language routine of the problem
with three reads for example so we're
working on a math problem i'm simply
going to start off by asking you to read
the problem and then i'm going to ask
you what is this problem asking us about
so and simply asking that question i'm
getting an understanding of how my
students are interpreting that and then
we might read the question again and
then i'll say okay well what information
do we need in order to solve this
problem so that gives me insight into
the student's level of readiness in
terms of
you know background knowledge that they
might need
and so it's really helping me to unpack
the context and the purpose from my
students understanding teachers are
generally very well skilled at these
strategies that we might use another
thing we might do our entrance and exit
wait i think you said three reads is
there a third read did i hear the third
reading
okay let's go back so the three reasons
let's go back
problem and then i say okay what is this
problem about
and then you're telling me what you
think the problem is about
not confirming or affirming i just want
to know um the second read now i ask you
what are we trying to find out
so a little different there
you know what parents can use appearance
i hope you're taking note what are we
trying to find out and then we read the
the problem again and now i'm going to
ask you what information
might be useful to solve this so in
knowing the information now we're
starting to get what the math is behind
that
yeah that makes sense yes yes
then that sounds like the teacher would
get a lot of information about what the
student
knows and what they can do and all of
those from that kind of interaction
definitely i think the intent is to
really get behind what students are
thinking how are you thinking about the
math and that helps me to understand
what you know about the math and what
misconceptions you might have
yeah yeah what do you see as the the
biggest challenges teachers face in
teaching math and maybe it's different
for elementary students versus older
teachers of older students but just what
are some of the big challenges
i think the challenge that we face since
like time immemorial is it's been
illuminated and heightened during the
pandemic and that's the challenge of how
do i meet the needs of so many different
levels of readiness in my classroom if i
teach seventh grade math
but i have students who are academically
ready for content maybe at the fifth
grade level or i have students who might
be ready to be challenged a little more
at the 9th grade level as a 7th grade
math teacher the challenge for me then
becomes making sure i have a good depth
and breadth of understanding of the
content and that i can really scaffold
my instruction for my students no matter
where they are that is a huge challenge
that was heightened during the pandemic
and
when i say scaffolding that's um
literally thinking about how you might
build structures to help students grow
from where they are
in the learning does that make sense
kristin
yeah
it does it does and so now if we have
students where there's even
more
variability throughout the class of
where students are we've got even more
levels
that teachers are trying to address
what are some of the things they can do
if they have students who are at seven
different levels in
what they're what what they're trying to
learn
i think we want to first um encourage
teachers to stay grounded in what the
expectation and the standard is for the
students because if you immediate and
i'm only saying this from a teacher who
has the experience i've i've taught in a
classroom where you have students who
their literacy level
is pretty much non-existent versus
students who are just need to be
challenged and since a higher level math
i i have been there okay so i understand
the
um the immediate reaction to first go to
like the reality of the fact that i have
to cover so much content with all of
these students and i think if we start
at that point it feels too overwhelming
it can feel un pretty daunting that's a
daunting task so i think it's important
for our teachers to really get clear on
what is it that my students need to know
what's the grade level standard and what
are the expectations that i personally
hold
for my students um
you know i had just mentioned the
interrupted and unfinished learning
sometimes kristin when we have a lot of
interrupted learning it can lead to
assumptions
meaning
i can very easily assume
that my students
don't know
absc content simply because of the fact
that they miss so much
um and i think when we have assumptions
like that i have a colleague chase
nordegren he always says that
assumptions are a threat to equity and i
think in this case assumptions could be
a threat to equity because then it can
start to limit the content that our
students are exposed to
and ultimately what we want to do is
make sure that we're exposing our
students to grade level content
irregardless of where their readiness
level might be
and the challenge then for teachers is
how to do that that's the biggest
challenge that was a challenge i faced
throughout my entire career is helping
people understand
how do i keep my students engaged
at levels that honor where they are but
still hold the standard or expectation
for their grade level and i think that
is um
a matter of really getting clear on the
content so
let's break it make it real
yeah if i'm student who
really is still struggling with my
multiplication facts for the life of me
i cannot tell you what seven times six
is that trips me up every single time
that should not stop me from then being
able to learn about measurement in terms
of area and volume now the job becomes
for my teachers how do i still teach me
this this higher level concept
while still throwing in opportunities
for me to practice my facts that's a
that's a that's a daily challenge the
teachers face um so we want to make sure
that we
still expose students to that higher
level standard that we want them to be
at um another challenge for teachers
then is to really understand
their content across grade levels right
so we think about yes if i teach seventh
grade math i have to be a master
at that
but i also need to understand
third fourth and fifth grade math and
sixth grade and then eighth ninth and
tenth grade math uh because there are
some concepts that you teach
where you absolutely have to know
the prerequisite skills you have to know
them and so now my job then as a teacher
is figure out how do i leave that
knowing into the lessons does that make
sense kristin it it absolutely does and
i think that
point about
having both the exposure to grade level
skills and the ability to
start to practice those prerequisites
that are really necessary to be
successful on those grade level skills
is such a difficult balance there's only
so many hours in the day
of where students get and for a teacher
i can imagine do teachers need to
basically prepare lots of different
lessons
or how do they think about preparing say
that area unit and they know they have
some students that struggle with
multiplication but they have some
students who maybe already understand
volume and kind of increase how do how
do they go about that just the
preparation for
teaching that area standard
i feel overwhelmed just hearing that
question because if i were a teacher i
thought that i had to then plan a bunch
of different lessons
to meet the needs of all of my students
i would probably
decide that you know what i'd probably
need a break from teaching we don't want
to take that uh perspective of needing
to design
lessons that meet the needs of every
single student in the sense that i'm
designing a lesson for each student
group in my class that's not the
approach we want to take what we want to
do is
really make sure
we understand what the big lesson is
that we're teaching and in our lesson
design
building opportunities to really have
student discourse we have to have
students talking
telling how they're thinking and the
reason you're doing that is because
you're leveraging your students funds of
knowledge
in the classroom you're helping them to
support the instruction of this lesson
so
what does that mean in
layman's terms if i have
a student in my classroom who's really
struggling with those basic facts and
that's that's
keeping them from understanding how
we're doing the pythagorean theorem and
how we're drawing that out using
triangles to to figure it out um what i
want to do then is make sure i'm asking
questions that gets that student talking
about what they understand
and then possibly showing their work and
how they're thinking and then as a
teacher this gives me an opportunity now
to maybe take how my students are
thinking and start to tell a story right
so if i'm engaging in a lesson
and i know that i'm going to have a
group of students who are going to get
it right away
i'm not gonna start off by using their
work as an exemplar i wanna tell a story
that builds on on the math such that
i'm starting with the student who
is missing they might they might have
greater misconceptions right and then
i'm going to build on that and i'm going
to draw in another student students
sample work where they have a greater
understanding and in building that story
then students can start to have a better
understanding of the concept so that's a
very long-winded way of saying we're not
designing lessons uh you're not taking
one lesson and designing like 30 other
mini lessons to go with it what you're
doing is building opportunities in the
lesson that you're designing to uncover
what students know to give everybody an
opportunity to engage no matter what
they know right so if you are
just at the level of
the basic level on this ladder of
instruction that we're climbing
then i want to make sure you have a
voice in this discussion in this lesson
so i'm building in equitable
opportunities for everyone to
participate and in doing that
ultimately i'm going to meet my goal of
making sure that all students are
getting access to that top rung
and they're moving up the ladder
that makes sense that makes sense
so
both of us work for organizations that
believe that technology can potentially
have a role in helping to address this
particular problem of thinking about
differentiation and making sure that
students get the support they need and
access to grade level material and we're
we're really happy with our partnership
that's created something called map
accelerator to help teachers
meet some of those needs can you talk a
little bit about uh
that that map accelerator experience and
how it might fit into this
definitely
i'm really glad that you mentioned the
map accelerator so khan academy has
partnered with nwea and we've partnered
to create a map accelerator the reason
behind the partnership is one okay
khan academy by itself is a dynamic and
wonderful tool
when you bring in map
growth
which is our assessment map growth
is a test that students take and the
data their results tell us what they're
ready to learn it tells us what their
level of readiness is so it's not a test
of mastery it's not saying all right i'm
gonna test you on all the fifth grade
skills to see have you mastered those
it's gonna say you know i'm going to
test you on a plethora of skills and the
test is going to adjust based on how you
answer because what i'm trying to do is
figure out what's your zone for learning
what's your zone of proximal development
and then once i have that information
it's put into map accelerator
and then map accelerator designs or it
creates a learning path for me as a
student
that grows with me so it starts at my
zone
and as i progress through my zone and i
learn more it moves with me so it's just
a wonderful powerful tool that we have
to really support teachers and the wide
variety of student readiness in our
classroom
so we've got teachers doing all the
great things that you described with
those those activities that that are
accessible for students who have skill
gaps but also challenge other students
and all of that
and then paired with that we have this
tool that when students are working
individually can help really target
where they are based on those those map
growth scores and and help bring those
together so
that seems like a good balance how do
you see technology fitting into
classrooms
that is the key question now we have to
put this all in context we have to keep
in mind that our students have engaged
with technology over the past couple
years in a way that was very different
than how they engaged before
right so we have to be mindful of the
fact that our students
they feel some type of way about
technology they could feel overwhelmed
um they could have gotten into certain
routines so what we want to do is really
empower teachers and students to
have the routines that you want to
employ from map accelerator a routine
might be we've got 30 minutes a week
that's our map accelerator time that's
my khan academy time and then let's
create some rituals to support that and
the ritual might be
uh something like a talk it out tuesday
or a work it out wednesday or think
about it thursday so what we want to do
is create these rituals that engage
students and teachers together so we've
got the technology in the center but we
want to use our discourse to bring us
together so that it becomes an
interactive tool for everybody so a
teacher might say all right let's talk
it out tuesday what i want you to do
after your map accelerator time is go
back and find that one problem that you
kept getting stumped on you kept having
to hit the hint function for um the
problem just hm
you had a little struggle with it
productive struggle and what i want you
to do is now talk it out with a partner
in the classroom and in the talking it
out you might gain a little bit more
clarity or we could have a work it out
wednesday where
students are encouraged to go to their
caregivers and
show and tell
let them see a map accelerator
experience um and then work it out with
that person so that gives the student
opportunity to then step outside of
their head do their thinking out loud
and continue working on their path so i
think kristin what we want to do is
leverage technology in a way that's
really going to empower
our students right now really being
mindful about the experiences they've
had these past couple years
and how do we re-empower them
yeah i heard a couple things i heard the
peer-to-peer
learning piece going on and we know that
that's powerful
and then i heard them explaining to
a caregiver which then puts them where
it goes back to what we were talking
about at the beginning about using math
language with a
uh with an adult maybe and they can
become the expert and explain how it's
done i like both of those those ideas
where we're
not just having uh students sitting in
front of a computer isolated by
themselves but creating more of a
community around the technology
that's right we need to have so much
more discourse i mean that's what's
going to bring everything alive
yeah and i feel like after this past
year everyone is just really eager to
make those personal connections with
people that were more difficult when we
were when we were in uh all in
quarantine than in the coven situation
that's right so
we talked a bit about
the both the the past year and um how
those
students were faring and i one of the
biggest questions we got was how do we
keep students motivated how do we keep
them engaged in learning and what
they're doing so all right
what are tools are there technology
tools that could help keep students
engaged and what other suggestions do
you have for teachers yeah well one map
accelerator so we definitely want to
make sure that whatever whatever digital
tools that we're using with our young
people we're making it something so that
it's not it is a self-regulated tool for
them but we have to find ways to stay
engaged with them and get regularly
regular feedback from them and allow
them time to
share with us what they're doing so i
think that's one of the biggest tools
that we need to
employ i would love to see teachers
supporting students in goal setting more
because we all like to experience
success it feels good it empowers us
right it gives us inspiration and
motivation to keep moving forward and so
i would love to see teachers
working alongside students to set goals
with their map accelerator um and then
checking in on those goals regularly
short-term goals too so we're not
talking about by the end of the school
year i want you to be able to do this no
i might set a weekly goal because i have
weekly math accelerator time and that
goal could be around two or three skills
and i want to make sure that's an
achievable goal it feels achievable and
it's something that i can track my own
progress on and i can talk about it and
i can find reasons to celebrate
fanisha you're speaking my language i
can't tell you how often i talk about
goals and goal setting and that is a way
to motivate because yeah we are
motivated when we see success and when
we feel like we're going to be
successful
and
nothing shows success like past success
so yeah goal setting is is huge for me
so i love that you're
we're connected on that
so we're we're almost already out of
time we have a
a couple questions we have a question
from facebook from charles drayden who
uh has just this might be a good one to
end on i have a young child how can i
help him flourish in his math studies
and i like that question that that isn't
just succeed but flourish
so any any other tips you have that we
haven't gotten to
well thank you so much for that question
and thank you for chiming in on facebook
um i think it's really important for
parents and caregivers to find ways to
bring math alive
in our students everyday life and
sometimes people say i don't even know
how i use math in my everyday life
let me tell you one of my favorite books
it's a book called math curse it's a
children's book and it just talks about
how everything is a math problem so a
lot of our school students are starting
back in school
you might have an 8th grader who
doesn't have to wear a uniform to school
every day and they have the opportunity
to express themselves and you know at
that age it's all about them anyway and
so how does that turn into a math
problem you could ask them how many
different outfits could you put together
from these uh four or five items of
clothing that's a math problem uh you
might have a second grader who's totally
fascinated by the cicadas well here in
the midwest at least we have cicadas
i heard i've heard
yes and at nighttime the sound is
beautiful and so they might be so
fascinated by cicadas and grasshoppers
and crickets how does that turn into a
math problem i want you to go listen to
those insects and i want you to tell me
who's chirping the fastest uh so now
we're talking about frequency right so
everything becomes a math problem so
charles what i think you and other
parents can do is really find ways to
make math come alive in everyday life
because math is fun and it should be fun
and we have to all be able to say
that learning is fun let's not forget
that
that seems like a great note to end this
on thank you so much for for joining me
today it was great to hear your wisdom
and ideas and i love that you are out
there working with teachers to better
support students for learning
thank you so much kristen i always enjoy
working with khan academy thank you for
having me
excellent thank you all and we will see
you next time
you